good morning
the college of commissioner has adopted
today the european chips act
in the european ships act we are
combining investment
regulatory framework and the necessary
strategic partnerships
to make europe a leader in this market
that is so important
the global demand as you know for chips
is exponentially growing
chips are at the center of the global
technological race
they are of course also the bedrock of
our modern economies
and they are essential for the goods we
use on an everyday basis we have them in
our smartphones
we have them in our washing machines
during the pandemic for example we
needed them crucially in the life-saving
ventilators
are now for example with the energy
topics they are in the electricity grids
so
the chips are crucial in almost every
device
but the pandemic has also painfully
exposed
the vulnerability of chips supply chains
you will know that the global shortage
of chips has really slowed down our
recovery
we have seen that
whole production lines came to a
standstill for example with cars
while the demand was increasing we could
not deliver as needed because of the
lack of chips
so this european chips act comes
absolutely at the right time
and it has two main goals
the first goal is in the short term
to increase our resilience to future
crises
increase our resilience by
anticipating and thus avoiding supply
chains
chain disruptions
and the second part is of course looking
at the midterm and there to make europe
an industrial leader in this very
strategic market
for that we have set ourselves goals
we've set ourselves the goal to have in
2030 20
of the global uh market share of chips
production here in europe right now we
are at nine percent we want to go to 20
in 2030 but knowing that the demand in
the global market will double during
that time it means basically quadrupling
our efforts
european ships act will back this
ambition with considerable investment
it will enable 15 billion euros in
additional public and private investment
till 2030
and this comes on top
of 30 billion euros of public
investments that we have already planned
for example next generation eu
in horizon europe or in the
national budgets
and then these funds are to be matched
by further long-term private investments
now the european ships act will focus on
five specific areas the first is
research
in this field europe is already
excellent
we're
world leader
and now we are going basically from
strength to strength we will further
focus on small
energy efficient transistors and on
disruptive technologies for artificial
intelligence
the second focus can basically
summarized by the motto from the lab to
the fab
we need now to translate this excellence
in research i was just reflecting about
into industrial innovation so market
feasible products
and thus we will bridge the gap between
the laboratory
and the actual manufacturing in europe
and this leads me to the third point and
that is industry production
europe needs advanced production
facilities which come of course with a
huge upfront cost
we are there for
adapting our state aid rules of course
under strict conditions
and this will allow for the first time
public support
for european first of a kind
production facilities
and as they are first of a kind
they benefit all of europe
my fourth point is that we will also
support smaller innovative companies the
smes the startups we need we will
support them to find the employees that
have the skills that are needed
we will support them by finding the
industrial partners
and we will support them of course with
equity finance that is necessary
and finally
i come back where i started it's about
the supply chains
it should be clear that no country
and even no continent
can be entirely self-sufficient this is
impossible
europe will always work
to keep global markets open and to keep
them connected
this is in the world's interest it is in
our own interest too
but what we need to tackle is the
bottlenecks
that slow down our growth as we are just
experiencing it right now
and therefore europe will build
partnerships on chips
with like-minded partners for example
the united states or for example japan
it is about balanced interdependencies
and it is about reliability
with the european ships act we're
putting out the investment
and the strategy
but the key to our success
lies in europe's innovators
in our world-class researchers
in the people who have made our
continent prosper throughout the decades
europe is the continent
where all the industrial revolutions
have started
and europe can be the home of the next
industrial revolution too thank you so
much